[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry on
Francis Foster I'm Constance and Kissin
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about
now we're going to do things slightly
differently this week as a little thank
you to all the people who've like to
follow two very tweeted who've watched
our channel we're gonna give you some of
the funniest and best comments that
we've had tweeted at us or slandered us
over the over the weeks and months we've
been doing trigonometry so sit back
relax and enjoy guys let's start gently
yep
noodle bomb says great interview the
bloke with the red night reminds me of
Jason Schwartzman scare achter in
Rushmore
yeah but ok so right that's upset me
because if you if you watch watch more
you know that Jason Schwartzman
character is a massive prick but anyway
that's why they're trying to say man
yeah I think so as well next we have a
comment here from a hardcore hero what a
crossover exclamation mark Sargon and
interviewed by Jay and Neil from The
Inbetweeners can't believe it 47 likes
absolutely brilliant thanks mate there
you go I don't even know who they are
yeah exactly that's how foreign you are
magnet all right Tony G says when did
John Oliver start a podcast yeah well
John are the honest
yeah but we're coming for you John yeah
he's not watching doesn't matter egg
butty one Liam Gallagher and tan David
Tennant a brilliant interviewers 14
lights I like that because even though
it's sort of a nice comment slight hints
of racism sis just a touch well gonna
take you if you subscribed we don't care
about your racism just subscribe to the
channel absolutely and also as well
David Tennant is Scottish and therefore
cannot be turned can only be burnt yeah
gammon David McDonald says can't watch
it due to the ridiculously loud laugh of
the interviewer with the giant
triangular sideburns best viewed a 2.25
minutes I've been given a reference for
when you can get that yeah yeah triangle
sideburns next the dread pirate
I don't even know who that's the
reference that's the guy he used to run
Silk Road with this like secret
Marketplace on the dark web for drugs
and guns and child porn and that guy
okay I know what you're into constant
okay I like the brown guy he's good at
his job
hey I told you I don't mind the racism
2qt complements subscribe to the channel
we're all good
Mike Jarrett's is so great to find more
Brits doing stuff like this
I have far too much American politics in
my subs feed and then he replied I never
would have had Bradley Wiggins down as
political out there you got absolutely
not
though recycling me well jr. genuinely
can't ride a bike
so there we go all right well I do like
Fred Perry I do like the mod look and I
do like taking drugs in order to boost
my performance so me and Bradley I've
got a lot in common snakes it I'll take
certain all right certain never thought
there would be dollar five Indians in
Britain well done Altec you massive knob
what did you [ __ ] subscribe though I
don't care about the racism just
subscribe right he's talking about me
right I'm guessing it yeah yeah don't
know yeah thought you were $5 in D I
don't even know what a $5 in viennese
we're gonna have to Google the show all
right
wait lifted says I need the guy on the
left to get a haircut I need that to
happen now
haha I think that was actually my bad
commenting well schopenhauer well done
my god I wish I had a name like
Constantine kissing what now [ __ ] off
you really done no knowing likes yeah
man throughout my childhood everybody
would always say to me my nickname was
constantly kissing again why is that a
bad nickname it's bad nickname because I
couldn't live up to it oh yes a point
being called a wanker was much more mad
yeah exactly
you've been married to talk for 12 years
maybe you're not constant and kissing no
not at all swimmy hold our Quinn says
the dude with the beetle say is the most
British bread that ever britta'd okay
there we go
I think there's just the reasonable cost
don't have been to him Russia and this
is from Mishka well you know on about
bands was our bread and butter we have a
TV show running for nearly 60
is dedicated to humor and sketch comedy
between various universities in your
face we didn't say in your face what you
meant
and that got no likes because everybody
knows Russians don't have a sense of
humor hey don't ever go to rush you're
gonna get killed now yeah hopefully the
same statistic says it just occurred
that the one guy may well be the hybrid
of Austin Powers and Baldrick and now I
can't unsee it doubt anyone anywho great
interview keep it up that is really
offensive so he's saying I'm looking
like Austin Powers but I'm also stupid
right someone the slightly less original
saying is that John Oliver's brother on
the left so we've done that yep keep up
and then quit Nick replies of course not
it's Noel Gallagher yeah all right let's
go to the bad ones and we've got some
psycho comics Oh so I call comments are
these are my favorite I don't like
either of these guys they smell like
progressives and Muslim apologists I
didn't realize it was them apologists
had a smell but there we go I'd smell
like them why Muslims predicted by a
progressive Islam sucks plus these two
[ __ ] voted to remain you [ __ ]
believed the lie the leading EU leaders
even EU with damaged economy you [ __ ]
sheep [ __ ] the global EU [ __ ] two
[ __ ] interviewing Sargon trigonometry
SJW third wave feminists three likes
sweet skates of 66 underneath commented
blue shirt guy may you really are dumb
how is it the morons like you were
allowed to teach question what I said
true that's valid yeah I agree
yeah I only watch this view because
video because Carl was in it I
definitely won Sun you know where we
stand on you Street skater 66 alright
and we check and we quite recently
replied we challenged all our guests by
probing and their views to get to the
core of their beliefs we do this with
respect to curiosity and balance if
that's not for you go what see and all
folks
street skater 66 incidentes got 22
subscribers nailing it Mike yeah
you just proved me to be correct about
your lack of intellect you try to insult
me but just make yourself look like [ __ ]
you for lift arrogant [ __ ] are the
reason other reason this country's
beyond repair
you made me boo like I'm seeing a commie
and you are definitely one of them my
god I'm gonna be honest with you
streaks gate 66 I think the reason
you're angry isn't because of me or our
interviews it's probably because you
haven't had sex in a while I just what
do you mean in a while ever ever
yeah yeah and it's never gonna happen
either so yeah stop trying yep Mapple
nutcase says very simply why are British
people so ugly
which is a question that has been on my
mind all the 20 years that I've written
well there you got I mean it's a
question on all of our minds next
this was charmingly and this sometimes
you should never judge a person by their
name you know because it is constant and
kissing mfa is constant if seen however
in this case I think we can the name of
this commentator is Eva Braun I have no
idea what Sargon is talking about with
Enoch Powell yes Enoch Powell was wrong
his predictions vamsi understated the
current situation for likes what was the
name of the commentator again Eva Braun
okay okay so we have the nice things
change
Duke vane says this is awesome thank you
James for putting this interview
together we need our liberals to be
liberal right jets and Black Sun rising
replied with liberalism is cancer like
next one we've got is we've got George
and Zog
I think I pronounced that correctly if I
haven't George my apologies excellent in
to be great start nailing it George
despite the fall and then had to put in
brackets in blue so that's me who would
sell his and his children's freedom to
the EU for four pieces of silver is that
all you get for selling your children's
freedom four pieces of silver exactly my
I'll be honest with you I don't know why
you told him no I exist my long in his
13 pieces of silver isn't is it 12 that
Judas sold him for thanks 12 to 12
pieces of silver 13 13 vodka me Wagner
Bonita Sandra gasps is that a real
surname sand Regas
so intriguers no bernie toss and Regas
so neat oh no yeah but it's melt Bernie
like Bernita with a no no no do not
thumbs up this comment and you'll be
pleased to know no one did great this
morning star and morning is a slight
pond because it's as into the morning
that we equate with sadness two of the
most open-minded great start there mate
Lib Todd Cox I've ever seen
Bravo great nothing like a backhanded
compliment is there might even horizon
says WTF a civil discussion where's all
the rich and someone called
differently-abled Muslim Jewish lesbian
of color applied with rough cabbage with
rough spell with ru double F 11
subscribers so in literally half now Sri
scale is 66 the call me in the blue
shirt is a [ __ ] and should be depleted
from clown world and on Denis tan
I thought clown world I swear I took my
girlfriend's little niece to clown world
anyway - some [ __ ] Oh in the third-world
country we were never asked so I'll go
and remember that London is a [ __ ]
actually we filmed this in inches II can
it's very nice
so English straightly to subscribers
nailing it mate these two look like
typical SOI boys I thought she was just
some of you put on your noodles anyway
chap in the blue t-shirt loves to do his
hair so he looked cool that's fine
thanks mate but the biceps and gut and
ever felt stress or attention nice try
to get true trying to use his loud
cockney voice and to feel big my nephew
is 11 is more a man sorry
never talk [ __ ] on the internet yes some
people have annoying I'm glad I've
inspired you to be a troll mate I'm sure
you never and then and then eat but then
he goes off at you so he's not all bad
all right and the other come to the
beginning they saying how [ __ ] his tea
was another guest said [ __ ] yeah cuz he
can't straighten a [ __ ] teabag get
your [ __ ] together senileb says all
three of these guys want manspreading
top lads
well that's what we're here for there we
go if the Ricker says I think I hate you
guys have a sub yeah that's a that's
what that's the kind of person we like
and finally last but very much not least
red DIMP 79 says these men are very wet
I didn't mean do you mean well I turned
on it done maybe maybe we just saw boys
who just get turned on easily maybe
we're just like your mom so thank you
very much if you have liked the channel
if you've subscribed if you've retweet
us if you've liked us on Facebook we
really are sincerely thankful for your
support
please keep telling people please keep
spreading the word and we've got a whole
raft of amazing guests coming right up
for you for you to enjoy
and remember we're at trigger pot on
Twitter tweet us if you've got ideas for
guests we should talk to tweet us
obviously we've got lots of abuse coming
at us keep that coming and anything else
you want to tweet us will will will get
stuck in with that so thank you very
much and we'll see you shortly
absolutely and please lay off the gut I
am going to the gym hello and put that
in as well okay the fat will everything
no I have to deal with in order to make
this a hit show
you